(rock music)
- [Corinna] I think the history
of women and motorcycling
is really interesting because women
have always been doing it.
When I started the Miss Fires,
I'd been riding for a really long time,
but, I never saw women.
The minute that we put the
call out there were 10 girls
and then, the next week, there were 20
and you know, six months
later, there's 150
and now, there's, you know,
over 250 across the United States.
We always joke that it was
a thing that we didn't know
that we needed until we had it
and then, we couldn't
imagine life without it.
I do have my own shop in New York City,
which, does custom motorcycle
seats and upholstery,
but, I'm currently run
away with the circus
with the Wall of Death.
(motorcycle engine)
The Wall of Death is,
it's wild.
They're riding motorcycles
sideways on a vertical wall.
Samantha Morgan who must be one
of the most famous 20th
century wall riders,
I work at the wall that she did ride at.
There are very few
industries where you have men
being inspired and following
in the footsteps of the woman,
not doing it for a woman, but,
because some lady blew their minds.
The Wall of Death is living history.
In 1916, the Van Buren sisters motorcycled
from Brooklyn to San Francisco to prove
that women could be dispatch
riders in World War I.
They were even arrested several times
for wearing men's clothing,
illegal in most states,
which, really was just protective gear
and after all that,
the Army still rejected
their applications.
That history and the list
of women over the years
that have done this is
important for me to keep going.
The really cool thing is trying
to connect younger generations of riders
to an older generation of riders
and so, I'm on my way to meet Becky Brown,
founder of Women in the Wind.
- I first started riding
motorcycles in 1976,
but, I didn't know one
single woman who rode.
So, I actually put an ad
in the local newspapers
and it really blossomed from there.
We now, have 135 chapters
of Women in the Wind.
We have 'em as far away as
New Zealand, Australia, Nepal.
- Traveling on the road
is absolutely freedom
to be able to hop on a
motorcycle and just go,
rain, hail, cold, and heat,
that bike gets me where I need to go.
Whether you're by yourself, with a friend,
or with a few people,
you would find adventure partners.
- Corinna, I'm so glad you could make it.
This is some of the girls
from my Toledo chapter.
- Just some of them?
- Just some of them.
(laugh)
I think that knowing that they
have a family of other women
to get together and ride
with, it's wonderful.
Women who ride motorcycles,
we're not afraid do anything.
It's an adventure.
(rock music)
(gentle music beat)